hey guys it is Wednesday and the second
public day of a three and we're bringing
you live shows impressions and gameplay
direct from the show floor so make sure
you're subscribed so you don't miss any
of our up-to-the-minute coverage for now
though here's what happened today
[Music]
telltale games today basically confirmed
that they're working on an original IP I
still think they should make an
overwatch game during an interview with
GameSpot
head of communications at telltale games
jobs Dhafir said quote an original new
IP is definitely still in our future it
may not be as immediate as the next few
things we have coming up we haven't been
able to say a lot about it in the last
few years
elsewhere in the interview store for
hinted that telltale might bring its
catalogue of games to set-top boxes and
possibly Netflix saying I think there's
a lot of space for telltale to move on
to platforms that most people don't even
really considered to be game systems it
would be unsolvable to think about
playing a grand theft auto game open
Netflix but it wouldn't be so
unfathomable to think about playing a
telltale game over a streaming video
service of that caliber in things that
are a little bit confusing Sony piped up
to explain why they're hesitant about
doing cross play with Microsoft and the
reason didn't make a lot of sense to us
earlier this week Microsoft announced
that minecraft will support cross play
with the Nintendo switch and appeared
hopeful that Sony would also get on
board suffice it to say they will not
one reason why appears to have been
posted by Playstation exact Jim Ryan who
told Eurogamer that while they are
always interested in discussing this
sort of thing with companies quote we've
got to be mindful about responsibility
to our install base minecraft the
demographic playing that you know as
well as I do it's all ages but it's also
very young we have a contract with the
people who go online with us that we
look after them and they are within the
PlayStation curated universe exposing
what in many cases our children to
external influences we have no ability
to manage or look after it's something
we have to think about very carefully
interpret that one as you will dan how
would you summarize your III so far
basically just analyzing Hideo Kojima's
tweets to try and ascertain exactly
where he is at the conference so I can
accidentally bump into him okay well
while you were doing that Konami delayed
Metal Gear survived Konami told polygon
the release has been pushed back a few
months and plays should expect it in
early 2018 the extra time will be used
to polish
the game for release Metal Gear survive
is a spin-off of the tactical espionage
series set in the mgs 5 universe
it features single and multiplayer modes
where players must work together to
survive waves of zombies Konami was
criticized for the zombie plot line when
they unveiled the game last year
following their rocky split from her
there Kojima Kojima wait in saying it's
odd that a Metal Gear game would have
zombies in it seemingly forgetting the
man who shoots wasps from his mouth and
that the President of the United States
is actually the protagonists evil
triplet brother and that's everything
for games what news for today be sure
you're subscribe to us on YouTube so you
don't miss anything and go grab the game
spot now app it's completely free and
available on Android and iOS
cool that's not how an app works at all